僕たち
大そんなに長くないんだそんな悲しいこと言うなよ
俺たちまたデータばっかりじゃないかごめんはじめ
でも
およしをすぐために抹茶の葉芸バーン
諦めんな
藤目
なんだよ僕たちの最後の願いを聞いて
んああああ
俺でできることだったら何だってするよ僕たちを食べて
俺でそんなことはできない
俺にそんなことできない始めこのままだと僕とつのためになってしまうんだ
だからお願い
せめてせめて初めに鮫られたいんだ
うふ
をだった
雨西ビルわかったよ
俺がお前らもやしよう
美味しくする
かもよこんにちはじゃあ病理金というから始めした場です今日も早速クッキングをやっ
ていきましょう
実はもやしってすごいセンターがあっていうなんだ
だからもやしの一日放置するだけでもすごい悪くなってしまうというわけで今日はこの
私天才料理がはじめがみんなでの簡単に作れるレシピは僕ら感覚と
ノリで誰でも簡単に作れるもやしの日和を作ってみようと思います
では行こう
味で食べてるかわかんないですよね際様はこちらメイン今べんじトレに比べ
賢明です a
所に行くと政治パンもそしてメインの
4 se
何もわからなくとりあえず
水まわり笑おうとりあえず水廻り笑います
なんでこんなこと気にやりだすかというと10館に帰ってさ
マジで料理しなきゃと思った理由だとれたや采配を水洗いしていきましょう
ran
かなぁーっ
スターターラファーパーラーファルパラゴンアナ
タバコもわからんからね大きい役者はそろったお肉ケアとりあえずも入ったやついた方
がいい気がするボディ磨きましょう
ok オイルをじゃないと焦げるって聞いたんだよ
お外
あっっ bar map
ああああああ
ran
やっぱ強いございます
すまんやねぇまずみんな早いねー動い早いロッテの焼肉のたれれます
4 c 4 ok ばそんなされカームキーが姉の同氏は彼はが効きがないのだと大根
おろしねなんとか
全然ダメだを燃やし入れようかでキャベツキャッキャれているよ
キャベツ入れましょういいよ
千切りかんですよネギもネギもこの歳で行ってみは多いよ
体にいいからねネギは今纏ってんだよねーいやーここでクリ抜かないと駄目なんですよ
いいんじゃないこんな感じで
ok ここでもやしは打ち込みますファイアーっ
あっつパッカーズしっかり肉じるとは絡めます
ゆたこサビにを受けますです
なんか違うんだ
したいっ
待て魚肉ソーセージますれてかいい
バッ
木6月らちょっとピリ辛カーンなくていきたいねキムチでちょっとでいいねちょっと服
にガーターん
ok ok ok ok ok これでしばらくいただきましょう
1ならまず何も見てないからねほんと完全感覚 dreamer だったから ok
ん
pe
関西
完全感覚
も安いためこんなね味もないもやしを何とかして作ったのがこちらのはも安いため僕の
中でも安いためじゃありませんこれは立派な創作料理
もう何も見てないからホントにマジ感覚で作ったれただけマスタング称賛
いただきます
熱いいただけますうん
ああうまいぞ甘いは言うまいうーん
グニップソーセージを入れて松来ではなかったなマルロ味付けほぼ
的に降ったり打ち込んだぐらいであんまりしないんですけど美味しいですバッグ馬へ
を買われちょっとねぇ
料理やっていこうたまにしか出せないかもしれないんですけど頑張って料理やって
いこうと思います健康だしね
そう俺だってもを変えるのでちゃった犯しまくって内緒住職のんでない
それ実際をする健康ですよゴット不健康な生活してるんでこういう
実際からでもいいからしっかりやっていければいいなと思いますみなさんぜひやってみ
てください
じゃあだ
par
ん
me